[creator] okay so I have Polaris working on the background more like it added some stars
[creator] but I still don't like everything else I don't know so I asked it to add like
[creator] galaxies like nebula that type of stuff that are closer to the drifter star game
[creator] so we'll see what we get the annoying part is every time it finishes something
[creator] I can't actually progress in the game so I think I'm gonna have it add like a
[creator] menu of things that I can like actually start from or like start as like maybe I
[creator] want to start as a ringed planet or whatever. I also remember seeing
[creator] something where like running into bigger objects yeah like it's not actually
[creator] damaging me. Oh no it's definitely damaging me. I was looking at the wrong
[creator] yeah so for testing for testing I'm gonna make it to where I can start as any
[creator] planet and object so while I'm playing every time we make an update after we
[creator] start my progress can we add like a menu like a developer menu or something where
[creator] I can choose what planet or evolution stage to start as so I can test them
[creator] We're currently making an update after whatever let's go ahead and merge that or push that whatever commit it
[agent_tts] Polaris is done.
[creator] Okay, see if this is what I was talking about. This looks a lot better. I like this a lot actually
[creator] So I have to end up adding
[creator] Like capture settings. I don't know if I'll do that or not to be honest
[creator] I might leave that out of this the way it's not like copying every single thing from drifter star
[creator] Even though it's copied everything else
[creator] So yeah, we're going to let it add this developer start menu and then I'll come back.